okay this is from uh the directory that
this is from the complete directory of
prime time tv shows
uh and this is their little uh capsule
summary of batman the animated series
gotham city's caped crusader returned in
primetime television in this animated
series that was much more somber in tone
than either the 1960s live-action batman
or the animated versions that had run in
the 70s and 80s
this animated series was produced by tim
burton
i don't think that's true
batman the animated series really
changed the way people were making
animated
drama this was not the usual fare
for kids entertainment
[Music]
we weren't just reinventing batman
batman's villain gallery was all being
reinvented
fox did not give us a lot of notes they
had some overall general notes but at
least at first
they were pretty hands off i always look
back at this series
and i am stunned at the stories that we
got away with telling
we did push back aggressively because we
felt like we kind of had to
there was many many days when i would
drive home and think oh i'm going to get
fired tomorrow
[Music]
we got an education while we were
producing this series and it really was
like watching these mini movies
we didn't treat them like a tv show we
treated them like a motion
[Music]
picture
[Music]
[Music]
we knew what we didn't want we didn't
want the show
to seem like every other adventure show
on tv
we wanted the show to be appealing to
kids because we knew
that it was you know they were our
primary intended audience but at the
same time we wanted to show that we
ourselves would watch as adults
every single project is a puzzle and
every puzzle has only one set of right
pieces
and batman the animated series every
single piece
was the right piece to the puzzle
this was a a big paradigm shift in
animation
this batman series everybody looked at
superheroes differently everybody looked
at cartoons differently the challenge
was it was in the beginning
and and convincing the powers that be
that this look and the edginess of it
could be successful that um oh it's so
dark
yes that's what it's good that's what's
good about it
and everybody was like i don't know
so getting over that hurdle to the point
where they'd let us go that way that was
the biggest challenge
fortunately you know eric and i were
kind of in the right place at the right
time
you know we happened to be working at
warner brothers when you know
that the prospect of doing an animated
batman show came up and
you know it was you know jeans like
dangling that brass ring we're like okay
grab it
[Music]
there's there's just uh artistic
integrity that was
inherent to this series and and it was
absolutely because of all of the people
that really cared about what they were
working on and put their whole selves
into it
and it just shows in the work and the
fact that it resonates with people
and fans as long as it has is a
testament to it there's no explanation
other than that because it's just an
animated show but
the fact that it had that impression for
me
is a result of the fact that you know
that passion lives
within the you know the entire creation
of that
of that experience so to be part of that
collective
is just truly unique
[Music]
the 66 batman show with adam west was
actually my first exposure to batman as
a character it was like
my gateway drug
it was a show that we could watch with
our parents and everybody was
entertained
it was very cartoony so it was all that
pop
pow kind of warhol pop art kind of way
of
viewing the story there was just
something about it you know
the the whole larger than life aspect of
it you know the costumes and the sets
i was really invested in the show
because for crazy villains like the
penguin and the joker and everything
it really did seem to be sort of life
and death stakes
and then a year later there was a scene
where batman is singing
i'm called little buttercup to robin and
i'm going like that i'm out
i can't take this seriously
people love that show but it's not at
all what
bruce tim was going to be going for in
this show and i liked the comedy of it i
liked the silliness of it it didn't
scare me
but then we made a cartoon series that
was pretty damn scary
[Music]
once you got into the mid to late 80s
obviously there was a seminal
change in the type of stories that we're
told some of the most iconic batman
stories of all time came out at that
point
with year one dark knight returns
killing joke
the thing that that really changed for
me was the dark knight returns
uh graphic novel by frank miller i think
for everyone
there were new edges for the kind of
stories you could tell with batman
and it really redefined batman's stories
ever since the late 80s was
it was time for batman the whole world
was saying we want some batman
and that was well even before the movie
came out before tim burton's movie came
out
you know when i first got into the
business when i got into the animation
business
it was a pretty dark time for the
industry as a whole
there were the three networks that was
all you had and this the animation was
all saturday morning and
a lot of it was because they had a
requirement to film
to fill a certain amount of children's
programming
it was always very children oriented
even the action adventure shows and
they were very formularized you had to
have a
an interesting sidekick all the time and
and almost
always you had to have a funny animal
character so when you did a show like
super friends or something it you know
as somebody who had grown up with dc
comics it was like
well not not the way i would have done
it
[Music]
the network had a very skewed vision of
what they felt
kids wanted to see so it's all shows
about kids and kid
issues and it's not really funny
i started animation in 81 to hannah
barbera
the landscape was that animation was
pretty much
dedicated to kids 2-11 and almost all of
it was on saturday morning
[Music]
they always had in mind whatever the
show was is this going to be okay for
two euros
and that's what held back for me
a lot of creativity they had to worry
about making sure
that the toys were sold but also keeping
the various pressure groups off their
backs and there was plenty of that
uh not just like the pta but there were
various
action for children's television you
know a lot of these people were
constantly being called
up to congress you know to explain
themselves
children's programming back then it was
really rough
congress got involved and you know how
great things are when congress gets
involved
the answer is no
they would say make it goofy make it
wacky make it
zany but they had no idea what that was
it was never funny
it was just sort of on
[Music]
we had a wonderful broadcast standards
woman on the show avery coburn
she understood this was an afternoon
show
and that we would be appealing to an
older
bunch of kids that there would be guns
and there would be fist fights
if there's something awry she would have
an answer for us
i've had to do this at countless parties
what do you do bsmp
what is that and i usually i tell them
and they still don't get it and then i
wind up saying
you know i censor the shows
[Music]
but really i don't think of it as that i
think of it
as an editor would work with a writer
on a book
she is an unsung hero of this thing
because
if we had had a normal broadcast
standards person
from like the 60s or 70s
um i would have i would have been flayed
alive
you couldn't have someone
hit someone with a frying pan
[Music]
because a chat would have access to a
frying pan
you know you'd have to show seat belts
when a child rode in a car all of these
examples
of a general policy to keep kids safe
the idea came to try and create a
saturday morning network that was that
was going to be the very first one
created since the very early 50s
we have to have cartoons we have to have
advertisers
we have to have eyeballs but what about
the content how's the content going to
be different
um because now you're talking 1990 and
not 1952.
we decided that we were going to do
something
different and it would be a show aimed
at comic book
lovers in their tweens we would go over
every scene
and all the action and talk about
standards
i definitely had great respect for those
people that
were producing this show
i started working in the 80s and uh
the very first show i worked on was was
a very
it was a puppy show for abc
[Music]
you know they had the wuzzles and uh
gummy bears
so we're talking fairly light fair the
early part of the 80s we were pushing
the wheel
and we were doing what we could in
saturday morning but
it was very restrictive with the
programming rules with
broadcast standards it began to get hard
to come up with stories
that would interest me the writer as
well as the kids
because of the bsnp pressures
i had to make shows that were
essentially you know action shows
but the action had to be so toned down
that you could hardly call an action
show
you ended up with having the hero
standing around talking a lot you won't
get away with this you're rotten rug
jackie
don't worry general we'll take care of
him we had the army in there but they
weren't allowed to have weapons
no guns were ever allowed they could
have shovels
i worked on the last incarnation
of super friends with alan burnett at
hanna-barbera
and it was very frustrating trying to
tell a superhero story
at that time uh on the networks be
careful robin
one slip and we're done i was about five
shows into it
and i said you know i'm going to have
somebody
shrink the superheroes so that they
fight small things
and that that's a sign that there's
trouble when you shrink your superheroes
because that's you're desperate for
stories
you won't be bugging me much longer we
have to see
where robin kicks a spider off a table
that's
gonna attack them
and uh and we got the bsnp note
is the spider okay we have to show the
spiders
is okay and so we had a panel put in the
storyboard where you see the spider
crawling away that first year on super
friends was just
i i don't even wanna i've never gone
back to see them i'm sorry dr gulliver
but there's got to be a better way than
shrinking people
my introduction to the superhero world
in animation was the super friends
which i just thought was goofy as hell
forgive me it just was
the drawings were not good the voices
were god awful
and the scripts are really pretty bad
you were really had your hands tied in
terms of
how the stories worked out you could not
have conflict
you could not have violence of any sort
they didn't like punching i mean i'm
talking about superman hits a wall
instead of a person
but that was too violent the standards
and practices
were so restrictive that i remember in
the last season of super friends
we introduced dark side into it and
there was a great deal of conversation
about whether or not we could use
the name dark side or whether it was too
scary
that was the climate that we were in the
industry just wasn't thriving
[Music]
a lot of the earlier generation of the
you know the famous nine old men
the star animators from you know going
back to like the snow white days
a lot of them were you know retired
retiring or dying off and
there wasn't there didn't seem to be
like a whole new generation of people
who were being
mentored and um you know brought into
the business to
to further that there was really nobody
in the middle
age range doing animation there were
young guys
like myself and bruce tim and tom i
think is a little older
in our 20s and we were just starting our
careers like 79 80 81
and then there were the guys who had
been on the original disney features and
at warner brothers and they were all in
their late 70s and 80s and they're
looking to retire
and then here at warner brothers in 89 i
think is when we we first started doing
um tiny tunes
um that was our first big show as a as a
newly revamped studio for for tv
cartoons
uh unfortunately it was a huge hit
i met gene mccarty when i was working at
hanna-barbera and i had been
there for a number of years i've done a
lot of scooby but jean mccurdy was my
boss there she was in charge of all the
writers at
hanna-barbera and at some point she said
i can't do this anymore i'm out of here
[Music]
she was gone and she was over at warner
brothers
and they had no real production facility
going on at all at warner brothers
steven spielberg
and uh terry semel of warner brothers
got together one day and they said hey
let's make
sort of a junior version of looney tunes
i came to warner brothers it was late in
november it was right around
thanksgiving
and the first week in january of 1989
there was a press conference with
spielberg announcing we were going to
produce 65 half hours i had been there
what six weeks
[Music]
and they went to mccurdy who was in
charge of the animation department
which was really inactive and they said
who do we get to make this
they said you know what what's it what's
it going to take to put this together
because at first they were talking about
forming it out to
hb and i went no no no no you can do
this here
and she said she had the nerve to say
why don't you let us do it why don't you
let me
start a division of animation and they
said well
that's pretty chancy let's give it a try
i know some really good people
it's so it was like how am i gonna do
this i'm not
real sure and you know thank god for tom
ruger
who i'd worked with at hanna-barbera tom
was willing to come on board and take it
on
and really had a vision for what it
should be
i was fortunate enough to be the first
hire
and was asked to come in and do
development on tiny tunes at that point
warner brothers
they just wanted to please steven
spielberg spielberg was at his peak
so warner brothers was all in on getting
stephen
or maintaining steven's happiness
please mr spielberg we don't care if the
show's a piece of junk
i don't care if this is on budget or
over budget don't care if it's
you know a hit or a failure we don't
care if it's a disaster
all we care about is keeping steven
spielberg happy
but if steven's happy at the end of the
process we'll be happy because we'll
have this great relationship
[Music]
you know he was a big part of why tiny
toons had a lot more
money thrown at it than previous
cartoons for tv
they were so supportive in terms of
money
time all of that and
stephen attracted talent and the fact
that we wanted to be
really competitive and we're willing to
pay to be competitive
um really made a big difference we got
good people
i had a really decent sized budget we
had a decent sized schedule
and of course you know the writing and
animation was all really good it was
good
tiny tunes had happened at warner
brothers and that was kind of
the golden age of like the new revival
of animation in the 90s
frank miller's dark knight had come out
as a comic and then the michael keaton
tim burton batman came out so
things were pushing in a different
direction batman wise and comic wise
there was a revolution going on that was
changing the movie industry that was
changing the television industry that
was changing the comic book industry
and the two culprits behind this
were our first batman live action movie
in 1989
followed by batman the animated series
and you can't talk about one without
also talking about the other
tim burton's batman feature film was a
monster head just huge it was it was
like
printing money the revolutionary aspects
of this were amazing
tim had to wrestle with the concept
that any move he made could wind up
having people
unintentionally laugh at the movie
at batman at the situations that was
pretty
terrifying but he figured it out and
i'll never forget the day he said to me
you know michael in order to do this
seriously this movie is not going to be
about batman
and i said what are you talking about
he says nope this movie's got to be
about bruce wayne
it was very popular with kids the stage
was really set for batman
to appear in some form or another
warners wanted to make the cartoon fox
wanted to air it
and they realized that it was different
than than what
had gone before every single
genre movie since 1989
i don't care if it's a superhero if it's
a general comic book movie
if it's sci-fi whatever every single one
is still to this day being influenced by
the vision of tim burton
there was a lot of other adventure shows
on tv
they were pretty much all of them were
all toy times
prior to that a lot of the influence
came out of companies that wanted to
capitalize on
brands that may have had some life in
theatrical
and to build on that they could do an
episodic series which basically
advertised the toys
for a series so that the focus on
quality entertainment and
storytelling was not at the forefront
one thing i remember coming into work on
the batman animated series
was a sense of relief
that it was a new day in in animation
i remember the other writers and artists
on
the series talking about this this
opportunity
that that batman presented that kind of
the
uh the cuffs were off i think even to us
working on it was not we didn't believe
they were actually going to do anything
like
like we ended up creating
when we were finishing up the first
season of tiny toons my boss gene
mccurdy had a big
meeting with uh with with the entire
crew and basically said yeah you know
we're we're probably gonna do another
second season we're still waiting for
you to pick up on that and in the
meantime we're gonna develop other new
shows
and one of the things we're thinking
about developing is batman
as an animated property
warner brothers is doing a new batman
well i've heard that one before oh boy
here comes another super friends
these guys have been doing tiny tunes
i love tiny tunes but it's goofy comedy
it's tiny tunes
it started off very experimental at the
beginning jean mccurdy wanted to
see who on the crew would be interested
in doing a batman show and eric radomski
came up with this really
stunning uh background uh design where
he was
using very vibrant colors on black paper
to sort of mute the look and give it a
darker look
because of the tim burton influence i
chose to
present the piece i felt was influenced
by
the dark noir sort of beginnings and
picking up on tim burton's direction of
that first film
his influence on my sort of perspective
of the character
was probably the most influential
because i wasn't particularly a comic
book
reader as a as a kid eric's not really a
comic book fan
he is not like me he's not like a
lifelong comic book fan but
all he knew about batman was the adam
west show and the tim burton movie
and he was not even a fan of the adam
west show when he was a kid
growing up to see adam west and you know
the campy
uh television series you know kind of
left me uh
uninterested but he loved the first tim
burton movie
i mean that's why he was intimate doing
the batman show yeah
it's true the opportunity to bring some
influence into animation that could
at least be in line with what tim
burton's movie was
was just unique and that's kind of
why my direction came out the way that
it did in the very beginning was that
was the main
the main influence for me for what this
could be and if they were willing to
to consider that that was the only piece
that i had submitted
[Music]
bruce tim is the hero to those of us who
love and care about batman because
he was the right person at the right
moment in time
he was able to see the door opening
and jump in and pull it wide open
and bruce tim i think he's been drawing
batman all his life he
in some form or another and he just went
to his office
drew a model sheet within like about an
hour so i filled up an entire eight and
a half by eleven page of
just different batman designs so the
next time gene had one of these big
meetings i showed up with this sheet of
batman drawings and she went
wow that's really cool he brought it to
me you know i
did he's the one who said here this is
what i would do
okay that looks good you know
it wasn't hard it isn't hard to
recognize something that's working um
and he was working
it was good it's like yeah if we do a
batman cartoon that's exactly what he
should look like and she said yep that's
him
why don't you and eric work together
they were both great
and and they were it was an interesting
pairing because they were very different
personalities and styles but but each
very passionate about
what they did bruce tim and eric
radomski barely knew each other they you
know they had seen each other but
they were working on different things
jean literally called us together
basically said we like both of your take
on
uh you know at least an art direction
for this show
she took eric's background concepts and
married him with my character designs
said yeah i want you i want you guys to
make a batman short would you be
interested in producing a
sample piece uh that we could you know
see what this might look like as a show
you know like two minutes long whatever
two three minutes long
here's a certain amount of money go for
it you know
do exactly what you wanted to do and um
and we'll show it to fox
and hopefully they'll get a lighter fire
into them and say yeah let's make this
show
i remember bruce with his you know
tiny tunes storyboards and and
him being very happy that he could now
do this instead i remember that
i think it was uh maybe six weeks to
animate the whole piece
and then we did uh just a very basic mix
on it with the
existing music and sound effects and
bruce and i participated by
recording some of the fight sequences
because we couldn't afford real actors
at the time
so we were in the booth doing our grunts
and groans and
fisticuffs and by the time we got it
done
they had already signed the deal so but
what was good about it was that it gave
eric and i kind of a calling card
wow it was i'd never seen anything like
that and nobody had seen anything like
that
with the cinematic quality of it even
though it's just a you know a minute or
two long
it captures everything about batman
everyone
took a real liking to it we can do that
on a weekly basis that would be
awesome out of the blue gene had
called eric and iron door off and said
how would you guys like to produce the
show
i think both of us didn't really know
what the producing job was
i was a storyboard artist on on tiny
tunes when when that meeting happened
so at that point um i really had no
deeper ambitions or wider ambitions than
just you know
art directing you know the batman
cartoon if if it came to be
you know we were certainly dumbfounded
at the same time it was like
yeah sure okay so you know
it's like it was yeah i'd have to be
stupid to say no
until you walk out of the room and
literally go how in the hell are we
going to do this
we've never produced a show we don't
know certainly don't know budgets and
schedules and
what's going to be involved and who's
going to be involved and what
is our real role because we're literally
two artists that were just
production artists uh you know yesterday
and today they're asking us to produce
this series
we had a green light and we had a
deadline so we had to kind of get going
because we were i think too new
to realize the potential disaster it
could have been
we just trudged forward i ended up
working with a lot of people that i'd
never worked with before
but you know we had to take chances and
unfortunately a lot of it paid off
the art is useless if the stories aren't
any good
and when we first started we didn't even
have a story editor
gene was able to step in and understood
where we were coming from and actually
that brought us alan burnett in the
beginning because
we needed bruce and i neither of us had
experience as
writers alan is just
a god gene mccurdy and i go back a few
years
i was a page at nbc and got an
internship
at children's programs and the person
who hired me was g mccurdy
who's the manager of children's programs
at that time alan burnett has been part
of my life
my entire creative life i suppose her
television life so when i got to
hanna-barbera
allen was there as a writer and
one of the shows that we were going to
develop and try to sell with super
friends
dedicated to true justice and peace
and alan and i both felt
that it needed to be serious that it
should be
that it couldn't be adam west that we
needed to do
something that was really took the
characters seriously so we tried to
convince abc
that this would be the way to go and
they didn't want to do that i had
another vision of what kids would like
[Music]
she knew that he was a big comic book
fan and specifically a big batman fan
and she had since i think from the very
beginning of the show had tried to get
him
over to come work here and he was over
disney
you know doing one of the duck shows
and i kept saying to him that's
ridiculous you shouldn't be doing that
wait a second duck tales really come on
you know it's like
i mean i like duck tales but are you
kidding me it wasn't until he got the
assurances so that
we would be able to tell the kinds of
stories in an
honest way that he committed to come on
board
gene mccurdy promised me i'd have
guns and i'd have fist fights because i
wouldn't come over otherwise
and i didn't believe her i really didn't
and
and then they had a trailer and those
guns are going off and
fissile heading is great and
and i said even then i said to gene are
you this is okay
we can do this and she said yes yes you
can
almost we had a policy against
showing gun use we never showed impact
but
you hear the bullets and you see the
reaction
it was very moving very dramatic
but more mature more adult than you
would see in
any other show up to that
[Music]
stop
[Music]
i wanted allen and he was like no i'm
into contract
but i did not come over to warner
brothers until the very last
i didn't make a decision until the very
last day of my deal and i finally said
okay i'm going to come over
and so i was glad that i did he's made
his move
and so he took a chance and and came on
board um and from that point on
um it pretty much saved the show his
vision of the show was was
really really close to what what what
eric and i both wanted it to be
and it was true i could finally have
a noirish show
with guns and fights impactful stuff
he seemed to have a vision of the show
that was
very sharp and very smart and it was
really the words to bruce's uh visuals
and to eric's
uh you know stylizations it really was
like the missing piece
he was a little older than us and had
more experience and obviously
had his career as a writer prior but he
understood what we were trying
uh trying to do with the series as well
as he was a huge batman fan so he
uh i think he was able to assure
the executives at the time that we had a
solid team it wasn't just two rogue
you know young uh first-time producers
saying
leave us alone let's do whatever we want
to do so thank god for alan he put the
whole thing
he put all the pieces together and got
it up and running and
and and humming like a fine machine
and so the rest is history we you know
we were hiring people like kind of not
off the street
but people who didn't have much
experience or whatever um
glenn murakami was a guy who he had
never worked in the business he'd never
he'd never actually held a a paying art
job before
but he was a comic book fan and he
worked in a comic book shop i
will say it's the first time i felt like
i found my people i mean growing up and
being into comic books and movies and
illustration and stuff like that i think
that was the first time i found
a collection of people who all saw
all of it the same way that i did i
think everyone was striving for the same
goal
everyone wanted to make the best kind of
show that they could
so that's pretty unique i was too
kind of naive to know any better it came
as uh you know as just a team effort to
say we've got to get this thing done
i've got ideas you've got ideas that
clearly like what we did together let's
see what we can do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the shock of my life was i was sitting
down and bruce
shows me that trailer that they did
and i was like you got to be kidding me
you're doing fleischer superman
you've got to be kidding me you know
just just sign me up
warner brothers had seven minute
fleischer shorts of
superman that i thought were awesome
yeah gene
gene liked those uh fleischer cartoons
and she watched them on moviolas down in
the warner brothers basement
they were dramatic and the look of them
everything about it
eric and bruce wanted to make a series
like the placer superman
but they wanted to make it for the 90s
they wanted to make it even darker
and i think maybe i said something about
fleischer to them i probably did because
pleasure was always something that
haunted me i don't know why but it just
did
it was funny because eric and i were
both really big fans of the fleischer
superman cartoons
but we didn't actually want to just
recreate that look
we kind of wanted to put our own spin on
the superhero world you know in
incorporating film noir and german
expressionism and
art deco but we specifically were trying
to
do something that wasn't exactly
fleischer inspired
and then one day we were meeting with
eugene mccurdy
and she kind of said you know the show
should look like a fleischer superman
cartoon
it was like yes it should
it's like yeah we were trying to not do
that but it totally makes sense to do
that
so yeah why fight it so i may have
mentioned fleischer to them but
i mean it's so bruce tim those designs
that i
he would have done that that way anyway
but you know i don't know that i had to
say it out loud
he knew what he wanted to do i thought
it was an upgrade of the fleischer stuff
and i thought damn that's good that's
great visually
that thing was handled bruce and eric
and the entire
artistic staff and the director i mean
they had this thing visually
it was like uh it was poetry in motion i
mean they
they know how to tell a story without
dialogue
without sound
dark deco is a term that i came up with
on the spur of the moment one is just
because
it was combining two different things
the dark look of the show was something
that
eric and i were both really into trying
to achieve
we both wanted to bring like a kind of
an old-timey
film noir kind of sensibility to the
visuals
and that meant dark that meant like you
know just
having the show take place almost all
you know all the time at night
working with a lot of silhouette was
going to be
part and parcel of the show the darker
setting
lends itself to just the the graphic
side of what a comic book is and eric
had come up with this brilliant plan of
doing all the backgrounds on black
paper on blackboard i really liked it i
mean the idea of doing everything on the
black paper
was very stylish it really looks like
it's painted on black velvet
and it's just beautiful you're not
pulling drawings out of the light you're
pulling the
the drawing out of the darkness which is
of course where batman lives
having been a painter for the past you
know the two years prior to paying
i was like i want to paint that entire
city over and over and over again
and especially at night because all of
that dark imagery you've got to paint in
so it just occurred to me what if we
started with a dark environment and we
just brought light into it
and the deco aspect of it came basically
just from
me being a fan of architecture of that
era
batman was created in the 40s so it's
almost like it just never stopped being
the 40s
there's cell phones and there's vcrs but
it's art deco
it's like batman lives in this
forever art deco world so that's the way
we handled it
i mean the cars some of those cars look
like they come from
the giant cars of the 40s but then
there's
helicopters in the sky that don't look
like they were from the past at all but
something from the future they turn on
the tv and it's black and white
you know so it's like it's black and
white but yet you have this incredible
batmobile and batwing and these you know
very high-tech gadgets
there were computers and portable phones
and there was
technology of the time but done
and executed in a way that was more kind
of reminiscent of this you know
very classic look and feel
a lot of film noir this was the feeling
we wanted to have
with all the heavy blacks and the
shadows that high contrast
photography though especially in the 30s
and 40s and orson welles was like the
king of it
just where you'd get that shadow
just jet black black we
did that it was the universal monster
movies
and and cabinet of dr caligari and fritz
lang uh
metropolis as well as m and citizen kane
the whole concept of film noir that all
influenced the writers and the artists
and the editors of batman comics all of
that
were just as influential on the people
involved with batman the animated series
and you can see it you can see it clear
as day
we definitely were informed by noir
fiction and pulp stories
and hitchcock was kind of a guiding
light of how to tell a visual story how
to tell a clean visual story
how to deliver mood with camera this was
a warner brothers
gangster movie show that had a superhero
in it and noir not just stylistically
but thematically
where we were focusing on villains and
focusing on somebody who felt wronged
and wanted vengeance and
sympathetic people that actually were
the criminals and that's a very nuanced
rate
it's not just about dark shadows and and
and
cool buildings uh it it's about the
people
and and and and the darkness in society
it's really cool we early on decided we
wanted to have individual title cards
for each episode
this is something they used to do back
in the old days in classic cartoons
when they would have those wonderful
lobby cards you know and and going back
even further than that
hand-painted lobby cards you know so
that that kind of stuff was a great
throwback
[Music]
we thought okay why not you got nothing
better to do there's a little bit of
time left in those 24 hours of every day
why not throw in a title card as well so
unfortunately eric was really into the
whole idea
and uh he ended up designing
i would say most of those title cards
himself
hats off to him because those are those
to this day are still like
some of the coolest title cards you've
ever seen in a cartoon
when we came down to uh designing the
title sequence for the show
eric and i i don't remember whose idea
it was but
but between the two of us one of us said
well why don't we just redo that that
that pilot film that we did that sold
the show
with batman fighting some thugs on a
rooftop kind of thing
it was dark and gritty and
scary it's all shadows you don't
hardly see anything until batman's lit
up by
a bolt of lightning i think all along we
had planned
at some point to put you know batman as
a title
you know a series title on it and at
some point we
were just like well what image do we
want to cover up with that title because
they all look cool i don't think we need
the title you know who that guy is on
that building
the lightning's around him yeah you know
who that is
it just said this is something you've
never seen before and
you almost had to do it because it was
so compelling
and so that title sequence is it still
holds up it's
phenomenal
i think a lot of people think to adapt a
comic book into animation
they're trying to achieve the look of
the comic book previous uh attempts to
try and do
comic book things uh in animation
uh they tried to emulate the models
from the comic books very closely that
had a lot of anatomy in them
a lot of muscles a lot of curves and
everything like that
and one of the genius things that that
bruce and eric did
and bring this to the screen was they
simplified it
bruce was aware it needs to be animated
it needs to move around a lot how simple
can we make everything
every line you draw has to be duplicated
you know thousands and thousands of
times
and then you're painting them all uh
this is back when we were still doing
cell animation
oh my gosh so uh it really behooves you
to simplify your character design so
they don't have a lot of muscles and
rendering and all that stuff
voila we do that 19999 more times and we
have a 20-minute show
[Music]
the villains all had their own unique
design challenges
some of them i had a pretty clear idea
of what i wanted to do with
the two-faced character i pretty much
nailed him right out of the gate
[Music]
the most obvious thing i did with the
two-face was to simplify his
clothes because in the comics he
traditionally has like
like a purple suit on one side and like
an orange suit on the other and the
purple side
has like you know like like plaid
because in comics you can do that you
really want to like you know emphasize
you know that how different the two
sides of his personality is
and so i was looking at that in the
comics and i went well i'm not going to
animate i don't want anybody to try to
animate plaid
that's just way too many lines to
animate and purple and orange is
really ugly to look at as a color
combination
which is intentionally ugly but it was
just it was just i couldn't couldn't
stand to look at it and i thought well
wait a minute
you can't get any more opposite than
black and white so i'll make his
bad side you know dark and i'll make
his supposedly good side you know
blindingly white
and um it was such an obvious idea it
was kind of like in retrospect kind of
like surprised that nobody had ever done
it before
but it worked really great for our show
the funny thing about the bruce tim
style it is so appealing and so many
people
seem to think they can get it it's it's
a very tough thing to actually do
when i looked at the characters and saw
how simple the designs were
i thought well you know i guess i don't
i guess this will work i don't know
we'll see
ultimately it was a brilliant stroke
bruce tim's style really is you know
it's it's curves against lines i mean
it's people at disney we're doing that
for years and years and your own feature
we just utilized it down
in tv animation i was working at the
the don bluth studios in the early 80s
on
the video games and on the secret of nim
the whole don bluth
aesthetic was very much classical disney
that's where i first heard
concepts like straights against curves
and talking about you know the
different masses and stylizing the shape
so they'll animate well and
uh etc people loved it they ate it up
the interesting thing about bruce tim
though is
you know bruce tim is self-taught that's
the thing that i just find
wacky and remarkable and and maybe
that's what's made
him so unique um that he didn't have
anybody telling them
how to do it or what to do which is also
always an issue with bruce
for years when i was just drawing from
my own amusement i was uh
i pretty much taught myself how to draw
from um mostly from like uh
you know copying my favorite artists in
comic books
later on um when i got into the
animation business
dan de carlo was one of those artists
who got passed around a lot
and i really started paying attention to
his his comics and and the way he drew
uh girls especially um their their
facial features and so there's a
definite a little bit of dna dan de
carlo dna in the way i draw
um the female characters in the batman
show i think you can see it in
the smiles and the kind of heart-shaped
faces etc
alex toth was another artist that i um
kind of got to later
in in in my career he had designed a lot
of stuff for
um the hanna-barbera cartoons in the 60s
you know specifically space ghost
when i eventually got to design batman
for animation he was kind of a
subliminal design in the back of my head
i wasn't specifically
trying to draw like alex toth but
there's a ghost of an alex toth drawing
a space ghost drawing underneath my
batman drawing even though i wasn't
consciously you know channeling alex
toth but it was just kind of there and i
just kind of
it kind of came out with his animation
expertise and his comic book background
of
people like kirby and toth and his
experience of belief you know all
melded into this this bruce tim's style
and once i eventually got to do the
batman animated show
all that stuff kind of all kind of just
kind of rushed together and
became the batman style
it wasn't your typical filmation look or
hannah barbara
it was a design look that had never been
seen
on saturday morning
i used to have nightmares of my
nightmares were very literal my
nightmares were
taking artwork to bruce's office to show
him
here's my design bruce had a
bruce had a long a corner office
and uh he kept it very dark
and back then he could smoke in the
office so you'd knock on the door
and the room would be filled with smoke
and you'd have to walk
across this long room to get to him at
the end of his desk
and it was filled with toys but it was
dark and stuff like that and smoke
and he would look at the drawing and he
would sigh and then he would reach
down and pull a piece of paper and put
it over my drawing
and like redo my drawing and then i'd
look at it and i'd go
okay like he'd make it better and then
i'd have to take that
walk of shame back to my desk to redo
the drawing
but he was right i mean that was like a
um a good learning experience and little
by little
i think he could see that i was getting
it and then little by little he would
start going
okay don't do this okay do this
and um i apprenticed you know
i graduated up but i think that's rare
to apprentice like that i mean i learned
a ton
just by going through that process
there was just so much of the show to
design and before i had my own in-house
crew
to help me design the characters and we
had to kind of get going quickly
i actually enlisted some of my favorite
comic book artists i just reached out to
them
so i had nothing to lose so i reached
out to both mike mignola and to kevin
nolan
whom i i didn't know either one of them
but through dc
comics um you know we were working with
on the show i got their phone numbers
and i just called them up and said hey
i'm doing this this batman animated show
i'm a big fan of your work would you
like to do some design work for the show
and they both said okay sure
mike ended up designing mr freeze
the designs he came up with for you know
mr freeze is very much an old-school
kind of robotic
you know to me it looks like um lon
chaney in the old
man-made monster movie you try and
scrape off all of the barnacles of the
storytelling that have
accumulated over the years because there
have been so many stories told about
these characters
and try and get back to the essence of
what they are all that anybody knew
about mr freeze at that time
was that he was the jokey guy in the old
batman show who made weird ice puns
you know and he was either you know
dry as ice george sanders or he was you
know crazy auto premanger
i said but what if we took a character
like that and added emotional depth to
it
you look at heart of ice in episode that
paul wrote season one it's one of the
best episodes if not the best episode
of the series and it
took a character mr freeze that
previously
didn't have this origin didn't have this
emotional story and when
paul did what he did there it changed
the landscape
you know it changed people's
understanding of mr freeze and
the depth with which we were looking at
these villains
forever
[Music]
i didn't know paul well i hardly knew
him at all
we passed down the hallway and i knew
him from
the fact that he worked for lucas
everybody knew that
everybody that was a big buzz that
pauldini's writing the ewok show
because everybody wanted something like
that and he was
he was disenchanted at the time for
various reasons and was thinking of
making career move
leaving warner brothers and i wanted him
to stay on
because he's a good rider i was sort of
over on tiny tunes and sort of somewhere
else and i
kind of left the studio for a while to
work on some other stuff and
and i wasn't really sure if i wanted to
go back or to what degree i wanted to go
back
and i said don't you want you can't go
there's got to be something you want to
do he said well i have this idea
this idea for mr free's story
and he told me a sentence or two and i
said right
do it a day or so later he came back
with the outline
i'm reading this story and it was heart
of ice
and it was just great it was exactly
what i wanted and so he started writing
it then he was in
he was in he was back in by that time he
said you know
just come back and start writing and
it's like yeah all right this is this is
great now
it's it's a lot of fun and thank god
because he wrote uh some of the most
important scripts for that show
[Music]
mr freeze has never been been more
understandable more relatable to they
found a
human-ness in the villains they found a
why
and they let us know the why
how much can you feel for a character
like victor freeze
can you empathize with him can you
love a character like harley quinn who
makes bad decisions
and still keeps going back to this
maniac can you
empathize a little bit with the riddler
and his ongoing
need to try and prove himself over
batman
the idea is to make every character
human even the bad guys
part of that was paul part of that was
alan and part of it was
the two of them made sure that they had
a lot of writers
who were inclined to
take the character seriously and not
write in stereotypes
you know not have just you know some
crazy villain doing crazy stuff
the villains wanted things they wanted
thing human things those make you care
about the characters a little bit more
and
you know it's important because that
sets it up for the next generation they
can take it a step further and
and to make the characters a little more
human a little more funny
a little more interesting
in our show we were able to
end something without necessarily a
happy ending
uh the villain gets his comeuppance but
because we've related to the character
and and we felt sorry for them it's it's
a tragedy
again very noir very very noir
[Music]
all the villains are not just treated as
like toss away characters
it was a soap opera and it opened up the
possibilities
of animation not just being
for children that you could really get
involved into the characters
harvey dent that was such a
great character
one of the fastest storyboards i've ever
done
was the ending of that one where grace
is coming down the hallway
and he screams it's richard mall doing
that
death defying scream
when i i saw that played in an audience
at a convention once
and at the end when grace like
goes harvey and he turns to the camera
i heard this girl in the audience just
started sobbing
uncontrollably like it is it's so sad
it's so tragic
[Music]
villains suffer not because they're
villains
they suffered because of something they
wanted and it's not just some cheerful
happy ending usually
goodbye grace
[Music]
one of the things that was unique about
the working environment on the
batman show was that we were working as
a unit
that we were all together the writers
and the artists were all together
and that made a huge difference um it
meant that
if there was something that was unclear
in the script the director could come
down and say
hey what did you mean by this so there
was a lot more interaction
between the art and the writing staff
than there were on most
shows the show was just it was a
juggernaut it was just
huge and we were putting out i think
three scripts a month
something like that oh it was chaos
we i mean we we really were you know
flying by the seat of our pants it's
sherman oaks this is the animation
studio for warner brothers where they
put together the batman cartoon
and as you can see batman himself kind
of beating up on one of the animators
warner brothers started at the sherman
oaks galleria um
the large it was an imperial bank
building is the way we refer to it as
like a 14-story
building right next to what used to be a
shopping mall it was
basically just an office building um it
was uh i heard a lot of people
used to complain it was just like a
ratty old dump and
i don't know i'm used to working in
radial dumps almost every studio i've
ever worked in
um they were all kind of kind of low
rent we shared the floor with a real
wild group of people
i mean i remember there was a fist fight
one night uh yeah yay
it's a big you know bunch of offices and
there's a big bullpen area where there's
just a lot of cubicles and stuff it
looks like it could be
you know any any corporation you know
except that there's you know usually a
lot of artwork tacked up all over the
walls everywhere
everybody was making it up as we went
along i mean that was part of the fun of
it
was figuring out how to do it and how to
how to get the best out of people
and and to let people i was a real firm
believer in letting people work on what
it is that they
wanted to work on what they liked
and because that's when you're going to
get good work
there is a lot of fun there is a lot of
discord at times there are a lot of
fights because
everybody cared about characters
animators
and cartoons i think they're very
rebellious
and they need something to rebel against
and in order to help
feed that creative juice i don't like
this and it's kind of stupid i mean look
at
having jumping out of a third floor
window and he's walking away no
no why don't we have him sit there and
break his ankle and he had we see him in
a cast there you go well they wouldn't
do that
he said why not you know and then maybe
we get something else out of it that's
that's completely unrelated to
what we were even talking about that
just evolved
from that discussion but the important
was you would have those discussions
there was a lot of that type of
sort of creative energy
that was fun it was fun we had a good
time
as we had so many strongly talented
people
on on the series you know playing pranks
on people
while they're working keeps him seeing
images
of uh dan reba uh stumbling down the
hallway into these
booths in a batman costume you know get
in a fight with eric
you know stupid stuff like that this is
generally a very congenial place people
here really get along
it's lots of fun well oh you saw this
last hour there they go again
it's batman and the writer and you know
it's funny
we finally built a you know fancy studio
over at sherman oaks
over there that's when we started to
lose it i think
because um it was better when it was
still sort of the termite terrace field
just we weren't successful you know
you kind of want to be the scrappy
scrappy kids and we always had disney as
our foil
um you know we always thought we were
much better
we made a very good series
i'm not bragging i'm telling you after
the fact that
everybody put their heart and soul into
it and worked together
and we succeeded in making a series that
i'm so proud of
let's go 38 to 47.
we had andrea romano as our recording
director
and uh and she also cast the show the
real secret of the show was the casting
andrea studied acting uh in college
uh in new york and then she became
a stage manager i think and then she
became an agent and then she eventually
became a
director of animation but so she
understands
what actors go through she understands
the process
so the recording sessions were always
really wonderful
wonderful experience that everyone would
look forward to we you know had a
meeting with her
and kind of told her you know the kind
of
overall feel that we wanted the show to
have that would be you know
very much you know realistic and
straight um and serious
and uh not not high pitched and
super high energy you know like like say
tiny tones
i think we even mentioned that we said
yeah ideally it would sound like
a movie from the 1940s you know that
kind of fast-paced
but realistic you know kind of
naturalistic
and she seemed to get it immediately she
was good i know exactly what you want
for a show like batman i need
killer actors ideally actors with stage
credits because it's that energy that's
needed
i had never done an animated voice
before i had never auditioned for an
animated voice before
i was a stage actor i went to juilliard
i worked on broadway i worked
off-broadway work for joe papp at the
public i was a new york actor
for the single character of batman
itself i know i listen to well over 500
voices well over
so many actors we didn't fall in love
with anybody and
when you're casting something as awesome
as
batman for a series called batman you
want to fall in love with him you really
want to fall in love with him
i had done commercial voice-overs in new
york so i had a voice-over agent
and he said they're putting together a
new show over at warner brothers
i know you haven't done any animation
but why don't you go over give it a shot
it's batman and i said no i said
batman's been around forever it was on
when i was a kid
i didn't go with any preconceptions i
didn't go with any preconceived notions
or anticipation of who i was going to
meet i didn't know who bruce tim was i
didn't know who andrea romano was
i was just an actor going into an
audition
so we bring him in on the callbacks and
he walks through the door
and he asked a couple of very
intelligent questions and then
we let him audition for the voice of
batman and
it was truly the eureka moment that you
wish for
bruce and i looked at each other and
just you could see the stress of
months of auditions just fall from our
faces because
we had found batman it was remarkable
the trick over this long arc has been to
not let it get stale and i learned this
early on
batman is not the disguise
batman is who he went to is what what he
became
because of the tragedy of his childhood
it's where he found safety
it's where he is most comfortable in
that cave
and the suit of armor he puts on the
role he plays for the world
is bruce wayne that's the performance
and so once i found that about the
character
it really made sense to me it kept the
batman voice
from sounding artificial
and it kept bruce wayne from
it made him such a different persona
kevin conroy is just phenomenal but it's
not just him
i remember my agent called and left a
message on my answering machine
and he's like oh my god you're her
you're the girl you're the girl that's
the bat you're batgirl
and he was screaming and i was screaming
and i was like oh my god like it was
just such a huge thrill to
to book it i was excited about it but it
was really like
this is a really good job a really nice
job and i hope it lasts
you know that'll be nice to do a few
episodes you know here we are talking
about it 25 years later we're still
talking about that show
had no idea had no idea that something
like that was going to happen
andrea romano was able to you know she's
amazing in terms of
not only her ability to figure out who
who to put where
but to get to them and to convince them
to do it
every week there'd be some incredible
guest star an ephram zimblis jr and of
course arlene sorkin
it was just an amazing magical time
who thinks of going to paul williams to
be the penguin
it was perfect and it just sounded like
a weird place
because they were pulling guys ephram
zimbalist jr was a great idea
you know the guy had a voice but it's
like he wasn't
a voice actor up until that point
and neither was mark hamill actors all
live to a certain extent in a fantasy
world
and to me doing batman was a lifelong
dream in the sense that
i always thought that the character
actors had the most fun
oddly enough as fate would have it tim
curry who was voicing the joker for me
was not a favorite of one of the new
producers who came on the show
and truth be told i never would have
replaced tim curry i loved tim i thought
he was doing a beautiful job
but i could never please this producer
so now i have to find the joker
but we're at least two or three maybe
four episodes
into animation with tim curry's voice
so the animation is done the mouth flaps
exist there's an energy there's a
performance there's a timing
that i have to find an actor who can
bring their own joker to it
and voice mouth flap match
tune and sing because the characters
say in the christmas episode so i
auditioned audition audition people and
i'm like you know what i've got to give
mark a shot at this this might just be
the answer to our prayers mark hamill oh
my god do you think we can get him
mark walked in and he was
incredible one of the things that said
at the top of the
of the audition script don't
think nicholson what a
what a relief that was because i figured
if you're going to just try and
imitate jack nicholson you're going to
really suffer
because as wonderful he is in the movie
jack is jack all we can do is imitate
and that's not something i wanted to do
i remember hearing his audition for the
joker and it was the laugh
once i heard the laugh i was going like
oh god that's that's it
you're really sick you know that boss
it just sent goosebumps down my spine he
is
so inhabited that role and and it would
just
sort of physically take over his body as
he did it it was it was an amazing
transformation to watch
if the world decides to build a mount
rushmore
for the joker it's going to be
jack nicholson heath ledger and mark
hamill
because mark is the definitive voice of
the joker
the joker that you hear today on the
cartoon
by mark hamill is exactly the joker he
did for us when he walked in and
auditioned for us
it was manic it was funny and there was
a little element of tragedy to it there
was just a little bit of
like this this guy is a lost soul
and he doesn't care and that's what made
it scary
it was as if from childhood he had
thought about how he would voice the
joker
if he ever got the chance to do it
everyone was doing these incredible
villain characters
arlene wonderful as harley i
i brought her up and said hey you know
i'm kind of basing this character on my
friend she's a comedic actress how about
getting her to do the voice
and andrea was saying like okay i'll
give her a shot she came in and she had
this sort of warped
billie holiday quality to her voice and
the fact that she hadn't done voiceover
that made her want to
experiment and try different things and
and
she brought in a newness to to uh
through her performance into that
character and it really clicked
harley quinn is a great example what a
character created by uh paul dani and
bruce tim
and here she is this this
sort of zany sidekick to uh
the joker that it came from batman the
animation series and now
they're warner brothers is thinking of
giving her own movie franchise
i mean this thing really did create some
lasting uh images and some lasting
characters
so it was fun to have actors of that
caliber you know and
we had like almost the entire crew lined
up
um like a like a radio play a great
thing about recording
for warner brothers um and andrea romano
specifically
is they really like to get all the
actors together in a room
i can't say that i insisted upon it but
i i really
tried to always make that happen on
every series i directed
because a major part of acting is
reacting
so you have the other actors to bounce
things off of i wouldn't be
nearly as good in what i do if i didn't
have mark hamill
feeding me as the joker so typically
when there's a group cast record
all the actors will be in a semi-circle
facing this
the booth so that we could see the
director everyone's in the room together
and it's just one big room
and you have music stands and you've got
a microphone
and you've got headsets on so we would
all be sitting there
all of it except for mark hamill who
would always stand i always knew mark
was in the show because i'd come in
and there'd be one microphone stand
standing i said oh mark's in this
episode
you're really listening to each other
and playing off each other it's a very
collaborative world i would say a line
and maybe the other actor would pause
before saying something and that would
give me pause and make me think about
what are they thinking
this is what you do in every realm of
where good acting is involved and that
that situation where we were all in the
room together
that lent itself to that i wanted to
make sure that there was a sensitivity
to these pieces
and that's why you'll see where there
are emotional scenes that are played
i i let them breathe i wanted them to
breathe i wanted to take more time i
wanted the actors to make me cry and
they almost always did and if they
didn't i felt like i hadn't done my job
right andrea knew what to say to get the
actors to give the performance
that she and the other people in the
booth were expecting or envisioned so
feel free to ask questions as we go
along i'll describe the action that
i think is important for you to know and
we'll just go scene by scene so remember
the animation is done later we do the
voice first
and all we get is a
script with words on it when we record
it's up to
andrea to paint the pictures for us
and that's what she would do she would
really paint the pictures of what was
going on because she'd seen the
storyboards
and she would tell us you know uh okay
you're
you're in a helicopter and and the
mountain is coming
right at you and you know these kinds of
things you
you you couldn't necessarily picture or
get from the script there would be brief
descriptions
but she would really paint the picture
of it and if it wasn't quite the right
sound
especially like uh you know in the
fights you know
there are different kinds of fights you
know there's a difference between an uh
and an
oh so she would say okay now you're
getting kicked in the stomach
you know and she sees the storyboard
no you're getting really kicked hard in
the stomach so
you know those are you know those are
things that we would not be able to do
unless we had you know a wonderful
captain at the helm that she
you know was and is
i would never ask an actor to do
something that i wouldn't do
so i was right there with them i would
cry with them i would
angry with them i would yeah with them i
would do everything
i would do it first so that they could
see that it's okay
to to do it that broad it's okay to
you know to cry to yell to be you know
all those things
these are super real authentic emotional
pieces that we were working on and
that's part of why the show was
so well loved by the fans they felt that
authenticity
it was very collaborative how we came to
the energy of the show
and where the quiet moments needed to be
and and those are the moments that i
really love to direct where
you just take that breath that moment
and then a huge fight scene happens
[Music]
bruce is very upfront he did not want
a wall-to-wall music on his shows
you know at times sometimes i wish that
we had just a little bit
more but he was right in
saying that we need breathing space
absolutely
especially in these types of shows the
film noir
sometimes you just need a simple sound
effect you know
the dripping of the water you know
a rat scurrying across a sewer line or
something you know
that's all you needed you just let the
echo take it and that's
that's the music that little sound
effect carrying over an echo
plays as music because it does serves
the same purpose
music was equally as important and as
wonderful
and brilliant as all of the other
elements that came together and to say
that we
you know we knew that would happen would
be a complete
complete lie because all of those things
made
made the series become the iconic series
that it has become
[Music]
for the first time in almost any
animated show like that
we had real orchestral music
it wasn't a synthesizer
[Music]
it was real instrumentation and
we had shirley walker who was just one
of the greatest composers ever
in my mind she was such a delightful
person as well
she was phenomenal she came up with a
theme for batman that
is just haunting to this day it's a
haunting theme when we did tiny toons we
need to make
the music really important and steven
wanted to spend all the money on the
music we were spending a fortune
steven said to me well we have to have a
full orchestra
for these cartoons and i was like oh
nobody does that you know you record
these little sound bites stephen and
then you just cut them in
where you need them and you use them
over and over again and he was like
no we're not gonna do that and i was
like
oh okay you know i wasn't sure what that
meant well i made a lot of money
and so when we started batman there was
like well we have to have an orchestra i
mean that's what we do
that is now what warner animation does
we do full orchestra you know so it was
like
and so thank you steven god is the
orchestra
shirley walker wanted this batman
animated series very much
she really kind of stepped forward and
and said
you gotta let me uh score this
series she was just she was oh
god makes me get teary she was really a
gift
she was something else talk about a
strong woman
you know in that business and she had
worked for danny hoffman
and god the talent and the sound that
comes out of her
was something else
[Music]
i have very very specific memories of
the very first time she conducted an
orchestra
to our picture over at the lot
eric and i went over there and we're
sitting there in the control booth and
she's out there you know conducting the
orchestra
she runs the film and we hear the
orchestra you know power up and it's
playing you know that
that dynamic opening music to the first
episode on leather wings and it was like
you know
trombones and strings and it was like
really dark and spooky and gothic and it
was just like
wow it's like this sounds great i've
never heard a tv cartoon that sounds
like this it's like
yeah it was it was something
[Music]
she then whispers to me she's like over
half of these people are la philharmonic
players and this was a day job for them
and you just i don't even know what how
you describe that other than to go
how did i get so lucky i mean this is
just incredible and then of course they
start into the music and it's
just chills
[Applause]
[Music]
when i heard the score for that first
episode
it i i mean i just brought tears to your
eyes
it's just so beautiful and it's just i i
couldn't believe that they had like
they assembled like an orchestra it's
like one of the great moments
of my life
the first uh episode we got a tape it
was a
vhs tape sent to dc's offices
we all stopped working and we went to
the conference room and we watched on
leather wings
like regular people and we were thrilled
because it took
the comics seriously and
translated it in a way that we weren't
embarrassed by and that is not always
the case
so we were nervous to watch it but
and we didn't know what a bruce tim was
or a pauldini was at that time
but we were just thrilled and we just
then after that
we would watch them as they came in and
just
enjoy the show as fans and there's
nothing better for us
to be able to watch something and say we
don't have to
apologize for this at all and that again
does not happen all the time all shows
have a lifespan you start to run out of
stories
you start to run out of a new vision it
is
very hard to sustain something too long
and and it'll become detrimental when
you do
these have life spans i believe the
period of time when we were doing this
series
this was where you wanted to be in
animation this was where everybody
wanted to be
in animation and the big reason for that
is jean mccurdy she was the best
animation
executive bar none
i started as a secretary and 30 years
later i retired as president
of the animation division i think i was
the first division president
female division president of warner
brothers
i'm proud of that you know i have more
appreciation for that now
being out of it than i did when it was
happening and you're having you're just
doing your job
listen i had a great time i have
no regrets
i worked with fabulous people and
generous people jean had our back all
the time
all the damn time we could not have made
the show
without her running interference for us
yeah she was the enabler
she was the good parent and there was no
disciplinary parent
just do whatever you want we amused her
i think we were like little little
clowns that amused her
we were all so young you know i mean
we were all young and there's something
to be said for that
that there's a a juice there and a need
to
make your statement and and you have
you have a real fierce feeling that
you're right yeah even when you're not
uh-huh
and sometimes it works out we got a lot
of pushback from people
you know saying yeah who who are these
who are these two young punks you know
telling us this is how they want to do
the show it's like well that's not how
you make a show
you got to be gutsy you gotta break your
own rules and
and see where they get you and take some
chances and risk
upsetting a few people but you know more
often than not you'll you'll come up
with something kind of fun
the thing i miss the most are the people
and the interaction
the interaction not only with the people
themselves but with that creative
process
it's um watching people
wrestle with the concept and visualizing
it and
bringing it to life that's a rush that
is a real rush
and i mean i definitely miss
i don't miss all the peripheral
shenanigans that go on around choking
but that part of it i missed
i got to work so closely with such
creative people
as alan and sydney and
it was just wonderful
to um to be creative
in my job and to work with these people
who
were at the top of their form
and had this vision these visions of
you know what animation could be
and yeah it was a highlight of my career
for sure
people think of cartoons or comic books
as
oh that's just a cartoon or a comic book
that's
it's disposable it's kid stuff and we
just played it straight i think we were
all fans of it and we loved it
i'm trying to make it not a big mystical
thing
i think we just played it straight
when entertainment is done well it works
on a level
for kids and adults
i really think it's something that it
has embraced and and carried throughout
the years
you know i see people at conventions all
the time they're people who are like in
their 30s
you know saying oh yeah you know when i
was a kid your batman was like that's
why that was my first exposure to batman
and it's like well that's kind of cool
because like my first exposure to batman
was adam west
you know so it's kind of neat to be kind
of somebody's first
and when i go to cons it's another
opportunity for me to give back and say
thanks and they get so excited to meet
me
i mean i've had people pass out cry and
shake
all the time you know i was at a con
about six months ago and
there was a girl talking to me and i
looked over and i saw her mom like
really crying and again i've seen people
cry many times but there was something
unusual about her so i went over and i
said are you okay and she said
my daughter's autistic and she hasn't
spoken in five years
when she knew you were coming she wasn't
shut up for two weeks and i was like
wow like that's heavy that's heavy that
knowing she was gonna meet me
brought her back out and i take that
real seriously
i'm happy and amazed that the show has
had the lasting power that it has that
it's still
popular we have learned over the years
that other people can come in
with other creative perspectives
on what a superhero should be
or not be and they're not always quite
as successful
or true to the integrity of a character
so often you have artists who have the
vision
who have the foresight and want to break
the molds
and then you also have people who are
trained in the world
of business not wanting to rock the boat
when you have a formula
that has proven successful in the past
so you've got a resistance to change
to boldness into daring and
it is only when
both sides of the gemini coin come
together
and listen to each other and be
prepared to take risks
calculated risks that innovative things
get done
so until somebody breaks the mold and
gets the ability to do something new and
different
it doesn't get done it's not successful
that is
why this is so important
why the batman animated series
broke through boundaries and these were
hefty boundaries
and got people on the other side of the
coin to say okay let's give it a go
let's try it you are making a compelling
argument
we appreciate your vision and we want to
be supportive
of your vision let's take a calculated
risk on this
and go with it and the rewards
were incredible they always say this is
regarded as one of the best adaptations
of a comic book
ever done you know or or the best in
many cases
a lot of people feel it is and it's an
incredible honor to have worked on that
you know and to know you were
part of it and hopefully in some small
way contributed to that
a child grows up with it there are
certain elements that they really like
they you know they'll take with them
into their college years
they'll have a job and then they'll see
a figurine of a character and they'll
put it on their desk at work
i wonder if any of the shows that
that are that have been on over the last
maybe 10 years
we'll have that will have generated that
kind
of passion a quarter of a century from
now i don't know whether that will
happen
i call a lot of the stuff today
tonnage it's forgettable and it's not
the fault
of the writers it's not the fault of the
animators but i do think it's the fault
of people who are above them who are in
marketing
and merchandising and are fearful they
second-guess
the writers they second-guess the
artists most importantly
they second-guess the audience and you
can't have
a successful show if you're
second-guessing
your demographic because you'll you'll
never achieve anything
of merit
it was great to see words that we had
come up with
you know written down on a page and hear
those those lines come to life
and it's amazing how often people will
say to me that it's what got them into
not just batman but into comics you know
they become comic book fans that was
like
you know the batman animated series was
their gateway drug
so i was like well that's kind of cool
um but as to why
i don't know like i said it was i think
you kind of had to be there
when you embrace the fact of the amount
of talent that was involved
and sacrifices that everyone made
to make this series into what it became
it's just it's personally overwhelming
to to know that this is uh still
um as popular if not more 25 years later
and it's it really again it's just a
testament to
the true passion people the the artists
that worked on the show
had for the content and for uh you know
for the goal because it it took the team
effort to
pull this off and keep it consistent for
the time that it took
to to produce this show
after he died i was uh i was asked to go
to a
memorial lunch for bob kane's passing
it was this secret uh dining room
that studios have paul levitz
who's one of the smartest guys i i've
ever met
ever said uh this wonderful little
memorial statement about how bob kane
had created this character
who had a core that was so
strong and so deep
that it he
it was other writers could come in
and add their vision to this character
and change the world create the world do
things with him
and then let him go for the next
personal comment
that really is a remarkable thing and
the way paul said it was it was
beautiful
and that's how i felt about us the
batman group
at warner brothers that suddenly
this batman's character came to us
having had
all this added to them over the years by
other creators
and now it was our turn and we took our
turn
and then he goes away
for the next the next person so
it's quite i mean batman is
an amazing character with legs that will
go forever
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you